Donald Trump did something that actually takes
a little bit of careful planning.
He was able to combine slurs against native
Americans with antisemitic
tropes and one of the most unusual combinations
of ignorance and stereotyping and character
assassination that we've seen thus far in
the campaign.
So Trump went to a group of mostly Jewish
voters and warned them that Pocahontas, AKA
Elizabeth Warren is going to take all of their
dollars playing on the trope of the rich Jew
whose number one priority of course is hoarding
cash.
This was Donald Trump speaking to the Israel.
American council.
Trump shows up and starts talking to them
like everybody just loves Trump.
Of course, most are very liberal and don't
like Trump.
Although maybe this crowd was a little bit
different.
And at the big picture level, Donald Trump
seems to maybe recognize that because he actually
says, even though some of you don't like me,
you're not going to vote for Pocahontas cause
she'll take all your money.
What you care about most is money and that's
why even if you don't like me, you're going
to vote for me.
Take a look at what Donald Trump had to say.
A lot of you are in the real estate business
cause I know you very well.
You're brutal killers.
Not nice people at all, but you have to vote
for him.
You have no choice.
You're not going to vote for Pocahontas.
I can tell you
[inaudible]
you're not going to vote for the wealth tax.
Yeah, let's take 100% of your wealth away.
No, no.
Even if you don't like me, some of you don't.
Some of you, I don't like it all actually,
and you're going to be my biggest supporters
because you'll be out of business in rough
15 minutes if they get it.
What Trump is saying here is actually double
playing on an antisemitic trope.
Trump is playing on the idea of the rich Jew,
but he's also playing on the idea of the rich
Jew who doesn't like Donald Trump but values
their money over making the right political
choice that's best for the country.
So he suggests even if you don't like me,
you would vote for me anyway so that Pocahontas
doesn't take your money without maybe even
realizing it.
Donald Trump is playing off of multiple antisemitic
tropes there and then he adds Pocahontas to
it sort of as the cherry on top.
This is another version of the dual loyalty
trope.
I'll explain what I mean by that.
Often with American Jews.
There is this dual loyalty trope of how loyalty
to Israel may cloud the loyalty to the United
States.
Even for Jews who have never been to Israel
and are just Americans and there's no reason
to suggest that whatsoever.
In this case, what you have is the idea of
loyalty to their own wealth clouding or superseding
loyalty to the United States wherein Trump
is saying, even if you think I'm bad, you
would still vote for me in order to protect
your money from Pocahontas, Elizabeth Warren.
At another point in this total gong show speech,
Donald Trump actually said, if Jared Cushner
can't get middle East peace done, nobody can.
Which is of hilarious because we knew from
day one that Jared Cushner was maybe one of
the last people that should be involved in
negotiating middle, middle East peace, but
that's maybe a topic for a different day.
This has been the emo from the start.
We're going to do X, Y, Z.
It will all be super easy.
Then X, Y,Z is he doesn't happen.
Who knew?
It could have been so hard that even the best
person to do it, Jared Cushner wasn't able
to get it done.
So the slurs of Pocahontas continue, I guess
I should mention, even though it's pretty
obvious, Trump mentioned Warren's 100% wealth
tax plan.
As Trump suggests, I'm sure most of you know
that that's not true there.
There is no hundred percent wealth tax plan.
Can you imagine for a moment the outrage on
Fox news, if Barack Obama had said any of
these things, you have to vote for me.
You have no choice.
Anti-democratic, dictator Obama hinting at
declaring martial law.
But let a little about, if Jared Kushner can't
do it, it can't be done.
Can you imagine Barack Obama saying something
like, if Hillary Clinton as secretary of state
can't do it, it's simply can't be done.
Arrogant.
Pompous.
Obama thinks law school professors are the
only [inaudible].
Same thing.
Some of you don't like it at all.
Uh, but you are going to be my biggest supporters
because you'll be out of business in 15 minutes
if they get it.
What?
24 hour news cycle for days.
If Barack Obama were to have said something
like that, it's almost like Trump is saying
out loud what some antisemitic advisor told
him.
I imagined behind the scenes before Trump
goes on stage, someone comes up to Trump and
they say, listen, Donald, uh, these rich Jews
are gonna love you because they're not gonna
want to be wealth taxed by Pocahontas.
Okay, so just bear that in mind when you're
speaking to them.
Got it.
Most politicians then when they go out, they
don't repeat that stuff verbatim.
Trump, of course is not most politicians and
he repeats it all verbatim and again, just
a gong show, strange interview that on lots
of trumpets, even the inappropriate nature
of that speech would be completely lost on
them.
They would again say some of it was jokes
and then most of it is just Trump not cowtowing
to the politically correct crowd and simply
telling it like it is.
They are beyond reach.
But hopefully folks in our audience understand
what's going on here.